Prof: Okay,
today we're going to talk about
sex allocation theory,
and I would like to begin by
reminding you of where we're at
in the course.
We're in the middle of
micro-evolutionary evolutionary
biology,
the micro part,
and we are now applying the
ideas that we've developed to
try to understand the design of
phenotypes for reproductive
success.
This portion of the course
basically started with the
evolution of sex,
and then we saw that sexual-
the evolution of sex opened up
all sorts of possibilities for
genomic conflict in evolution,
and that gave us the image of
the organism as not necessarily
being optimized or just
adaptive.
The organism can be viewed as a
composite, and the parts of the
composite can be in conflict
with each other.
With life history evolution,
we've more or less shifted back
to a view of the organism as
being optimized in some sense.
I think we saw that most
clearly with the kestrel
parental investment and
investment in clutch size,
and in things like optimal
reaction norms for age and size
at maturity.
Now, when we go to sex
allocation, we are looking again
at how to optimize the life
history.
But the issue now is how much
should be invested in male
function and how much should be
invested in female function?
And this opens the doorway also
to alternative explanations.
Some of these patterns that
we're going to be looking at can
be seen as the result of more or
less an optimality argument,
that this is the best way it
could be done,
given the constraints on the
system,
but in other places it's
possible that there are
fundamental conflicts going on
and that nobody's winning,
that everybody's making the
best of a bad job.
And I think that you'll see
some of that when we get into
the frequency dependent parts of
sex allocation.
So sex allocation theory is
actually a part of evolutionary
ecology which has been extremely
successful.
It predicts the distribution of
reproductive effort among male
and female offspring,
or between male and female
function.
It makes a lot of successful
predictions.
There is a theorem at the heart
of this part of biology called
the Shaw-Mohler theorem,
which is very general in the
way it's formulated,
and it unites many previously
unrelated phenomena.
So the successful predictions,
and the bringing together in a
single explanatory framework of
a lot of stuff that was
previously seen as unconnected,
is a characteristic of any good
scientific theory.
After all, that's what the
Periodic Table does in
chemistry;
that's what Newton did with his
Laws of Motion.
So this is a good example of
success in evolutionary theory.
In order to get into this
field, we need to have a little
vocabulary building,
just so you can operate in the
literature.
If you're a botanist,
you call organisms that have
separate sexes dioecious,
and if you're a zoologist you
tend to call them
gonorchoristic.
The default condition in most
flowering plants is that they're
hermaphrodites and they have
both male and female parts in
the same flower.
But there are some striking
exceptions.
Papayas have separate male and
female sexes;
holly have separate male and
female plants;
and so forth.
So there are certainly
dioecious plants.
The default condition in most
animals is that the sexes are
separate.
So the default condition is
different in most flowering
plants and most higher animals.
Now if we're dealing with
sequential hermaphrodites,
then they can be either
protandric or protogynous.
We call them protandric--so
first male,
pro andros--if they're born as
males and change later to
females,
and we call them protogynous if
they are first females and then
change to males.
Okay?
The only human in mythology,
at least in Western mythology,
who has done something like
this was the Greek sage
Tiresias,
who was a prophet during the
Trojan War and is said to have
been,
in his lifetime,
both male and female,
having been changed by the
gods, rather than by his
hormones,
and was able to report on what
it's like.
You might want to go back and
check.
Now for the purposes of sex
allocation theory,
we define female function in a
number of different ways.
Okay?
It could either be the
proportion of offspring that are
female;
that could be a lot or a little.
It could be investment in
female versus male offspring;
so you have equal numbers of
both but you decide to invest
more in offspring of one sex
than the other.
Or in a sequential or
simultaneous hermaphrodite,
it's the proportion of lifetime
reproductive success gained
through reproduction as a
female.
So female function can have to
do with timing,
with investment and with
numbers;
male function is defined
similarly.
So there are some very basic
questions about sex allocation.
One is, what's the equilibrium
sex ratio?
What should we expect to see in
a population that has separate
sexes?
Another is if the species we're
dealing with is a sequential
hermaphrodite,
as what sex should that
organism be born,
and how old and large should it
be when it changes sex?
If it's a simultaneous
hermaphrodite,
then what would be the
allocation to male and female
function in simultaneous
hermaphrodites?
We're not going to talk about
this very much today,
but I would like to give you
just a little bit of natural
history.
There is a lovely Caribbean
fish called the Hamlet,
which is a simultaneous
hermaphrodite,
and it can make eggs and sperm
at the same time,
and they mate every day,
and when they get together to
mate,
there's the issue of who should
be male and who should be female
for this mating?
And the eggs are big and
expensive,
and the sperm is small and
cheap, and so you don't want to
get cheated by somebody who
never wants to be the female and
just makes sperm.
So what they've come up with is
a mating pattern where in order
to mate at all,
they more or less insist that
they trade roles and do it about
ten times,
so that they equal out.
So in the course of twenty
minutes,
they will switch back and forth
from being male to female,
and then each of them will have
put out roughly the same amount
of eggs and the same amount of
sperm.
So I just wanted you to have
that in the background as one of
the sort of paradigmatic
examples of how simultaneous
hermaphrodites have solved that
issue.
And then there's the
interesting issue--
and by the way,
this is something I stuck in
here this morning,
so those of you who have
printed out your PDFs,
this is new--when should
differential investment in
offspring of each sex depend on
social status?
And I stuck this question in
here, because in fact the
lecture deals with that.
We're going to come to the
Trivers-Willard hypothesis,
and we will see that social
status,
or physiological status,
really does affect sex
allocation quite a bit.
So these are all aspects
actually of one problem,
and that problem arises because
of this key fact.
Every diploid sexually produced
zygote is getting half of its
autosomal genes from its father
and half from its mother,
and that's also true of the
sequential and simultaneous
hermaphrodites;
okay, that's what it means to
be a sexual diploid.
And that has a consequence.
It means that the fitness
that's gained by an individual
through male function has to be
compared with fitness gained by
other individuals through male
function,
and similarly for fitness
gained through female function.
In other words,
male and female function are
equivalent paths to fitness.
Now in a number of
circumstances in evolutionary
biology it is advantageous to
use what I call 'the looking
backwards ploy' to develop an
intuition for why this is true.
Think about the genes in your
body--
you got half from your mom and
half from your dad--
and look backwards to where
they were sitting in
grandparents,
great-grandparents,
great-great-grandparents,
and so forth.
And if you go through that
branching tree,
going backwards,
you'll see that in each
generation half of them were
coming down through a female and
half of them were coming down
through a male,
and as they go forward,
into the future,
it's always going to be,
on average,
half of them coming down
through a male and half of them
coming down through a female.
This means essentially that
this statement,
male and female function are
equivalent paths to fitness,
is something that you could
derive by putting out the whole
genealogy of the family tree and
just counting the number of
times that genes had occurred in
male or female ancestors,
and you would discover that it
was 50:50.
Okay?
<<Request to turn off
cell phones>>
Okay, we start this kind of
analysis with the default
condition, which is the 50:50
sex ratio.
That's a photo of Ronald Fisher.
He came up with this idea.
He's one of the people,
by the way, who demonstrated
that Mendel's laws are
consistent with natural
selection.
He also invented quantitative
genetics, and he invented the
analysis of variance in
statistics.
He was a total autistic geek
and a nasty father,
and his daughter wrote a really
fascinating biography of what it
was like to grow up with this
guy,
who was a fulltime,
24/7 biologist,
and who kept all kinds of
plants and animals around the
house and kept breeding them,
but was not what you would call
a terribly empathetic,
emotional person.
And he also was a guy who was
nearly blind,
but who visualized most
problems geometrically.
He was very powerful
mathematically,
but Fisher essentially saw
things geometrically that most
people see algebraically.
So his theoretical writings can
be opaque at times.
But, this idea is pretty
straightforward:
If males and females are
equally good at producing male
and female offspring,
at all ages and sizes--so
everybody's pretty much on a
level playing field--
if mating's at random,
in a big, large population,
that's thoroughly mixed,
then the sex ratio should
evolve to 50:50 male/female
offspring.
Basically the reason that's
true is that the rarer sex has
an advantage.
The sex ratio is adjusted until
neither type is rarer than the
other, and that's probably the
most basic frequency dependent
equilibrium in biology.
You can see why that would be
true if you imagined that you
were a mutation that produced
only male offspring in a
population that was otherwise
producing all female offspring.
You would then have the only
males in that population,
and all of the offspring in the
next generation would be
carrying your genes.
You would increase in frequency.
You can see how it would work
in the other direction,
if you do this kind of mutation
invasion analysis,
by asking yourself,
what would happen if everybody
else in the population was male,
or everyone else in the
population only produced male
offspring,
and you're the only one to make
female offspring?
Well you get--all of the
grandchildren are yours.
Okay?
So you increase from the other
direction.
So if you imagine populations
that are being invaded by these
different alternatives,
they come together at the
middle, and it's only at 50:50
that there's an equilibrium.
This may be why sex chromosomes
evolved.
Okay?
We have sex chromosomes,
we have an X and Y chromosome.
That guarantees 50:50.
But before there were sex
chromosomes,
there was sex,
and there were evolutionary
dynamics,
and it may be that this is why
organisms with sex chromosomes
have evolved.
There are many other ways of
determining sex.
You don't have to have sex
chromosomes.
Crocodiles and turtles do it
with temperature.
Sometimes parasites determine
what sex you are;
Wolbachia will do that.
Sometimes sex is determined by
a quantitative process of many
genes, rather than having a sex
chromosome.
So this process,
which we find to be almost
intuitive because we have sex
chromosomes and that's what our
population does,
in fact is a special case.
But it appears that it would
have evolved out of this kind of
a situation: big populations
with fairly equal opportunities
for everybody.
If these assumptions are
violated, we get changes in the
optimal sex ratio,
and it's the Shaw-Mohler
theorem that predicts what would
happen when these assumptions
don't hold.
So let's have a look at it.
A mutation will invade a
population if it can increase
fitness through one sex more
than it decreases fitness
through the other.
And if we state that as an
inequality,
the change in male function
divided by average male
function,
plus the change in female
divided by average female
function,
needs to be greater than 0.
Here, little-m and little-f are
the average fitness through male
and female function in our
resident population.
So we're starting just at some
starting point in evolution,
and there's an average male and
female function,
and a mutation pops up that
changes male and female
function.
So its change is the critical
thing.
Is it changing one of them
enough to compensate enough for
the other?
So if the percent increase in
fitness through one sex is
greater than the percent
decrease through the other sex,
this mutation will invade,
and that will go on until a new
equilibrium is reached.
So this is more or less the
invasion criterion.
We're going to see three cases
in which it works pretty well.
There are more,
but I've just selected three
that are fairly dramatic.
One is local mate competition;
the next is sequential
hermaphrodites;
and the third is social rank in
sex allocation.
So the local mate competition
one is one that you're actually
already familiar with;
I've mentioned it.
I will also give a second
species, a mite,
that does something like this.
So what would the sex ratio be
if all of the grandchildren stem
from matings between brothers
and sisters?
Well you would make one son and
as many daughters as possible.
And to get there from a 50:50
sex ratio,
basically you can see,
I think, that if--
we can go stepwise--if the
fecundity of this creature--
it's a mite usually or
sometimes it's a wasp--
the fecundity might be say
twenty offspring,
and if it was at 50:50 sex
ratio, then the average mite in
the population would be making
ten sons and ten daughters.
But if all the sons are only
inseminating only those
daughters, then anybody that
made eleven daughters and nine
sons would have more
grandchildren;
twelve daughters and eight sons
would have even more
grandchildren;
and so forth,
until you get down to nineteen
daughters and just one son,
and that one son inseminates
all nineteen daughters,
and the nineteen daughters are
making almost twice as many
grandchildren as the ten
daughters would have.
So they're just gaining all the
way down, to the point where
there's just one son.
And that is exactly what
Acarophenax does.
It's a haplo-diploid parasitic
mite--
haplo-diploid means that the
males are haploid and the
females are diploid--
and there's incestuous
fertilization inside the mother.
So the one son inseminates all
of the daughters,
and then once that's
accomplished the son dies and
the daughters eat the mother,
from the inside.
So the curse on the House of
Atreus was peanuts,
compared to this.
This is what these things look
like.
This is a straw itch mite,
and any of you who have been
out in August,
cutting the lawn,
and then had little bites on
your legs,
were probably getting bitten by
this thing.
It makes 98% daughters,
and it has that kind of
lifecycle.
Okay, so that is the case where
the Shaw-Mohler theorem works
perfectly.
A mutation invading this
population is increasing the
number of grandchildren by
increasing female function,
and they are not losing
anything in male function
because that one son is still
capable of inseminating all the
daughters.
Now if we go to sequential
hermaphrodites,
it's useful to think of it
as--this would be either an age
or a size advantage model;
the size advantage model is
probably the more intuitive way
to think about it--
and this model is used to
answer the question,
into what sex should a
sequential hermaphrodite be
born;
so what should the baby be,
and then how old and how large
should it be when it changes
sex?
And the size advantage model
basically sketches out lines of
fitness,
increasing with size,
but they increase at different
rates,
and basically the argument is
you should be born into the sex
that has higher fitness when
you're small and then you should
change into the sex that has
higher fitness when you're big,
and you should change at the
point where the lines cross.
And if this line is higher here
for females,
and higher here for males,
we have protogyny,
and if it's higher here for
males, and higher here for
females,
we have protandry.
So you should be born as a
male, if your fitness as a male
when you're small is greater,
and then change into a female,
and you should be born as a
female and change if the biology
dictates that your fitness is
higher when you're big,
as a female--as a male.
And the reasons for this are
both physiological and social.
The default condition actually
is that small things do just
fine as males,
if there aren't any social
dominance interactions,
because a small male can still
make a lot of sperm.
But the fitness advantage
switches to being a female when
you're large,
if there aren't social
interactions,
because a big female can make a
lot of eggs.
A lot of this analysis is done
in fish, and the default
condition is pretty well
described in a lot of fish.
Small males do just fine in
matings if there aren't complex
social interactions,
if you don't have to fight in a
dominance hierarchy to get to a
mating.
And big females can make
enormous numbers of eggs.
A big female codfish,
a six-foot long female codfish
can make 100,000,000 eggs.
A big grouper can make
100,000,000 eggs.
So, let's go through a case of
protogyny, and one of the better
analyzed cases is the
blue-headed wrasse.
By the way, for those of you
who are snorkelers or divers,
all the members of the wrasses
and the parrot fish families are
sequential hermaphrodites,
and they are just about all
protogynous--
so they're born as females and
change to males--
and all of the members of the
grouper or sea bass family,
the Serranidae, are protandrous;
so they're born as males and
they change to females.
So if you see a big lunking
grouper, it's going to be a
female, and if you see a big
parrot fish, it's going to be a
male.
And some of them,
as you'll see in a minute,
look rather radically different
when they change sexes,
and these are fish families in
which figuring out that they
were actually just two different
sexes of the same species,
rather than two different
species, took a long time,
and some of the changes in
morphology and color and
behavior are really rather
remarkable.
So in Thalassoma,
the bluehead wrasse,
that's a case where they are
born as females and then they
change sex and turn into males,
and when people first started
doing experiments on this,
they went out and they pulled
the dominant male off of a reef,
and the dominant female
basically started behaving as a
male within twenty-four hours,
and within about six weeks she
has changed color and she has
changed the physiology of her
gonads and she's turned into a
male and she's functioning and
producing sperm and mating
perfectly successfully as a
male.
It takes a little while to
change.
It doesn't happen right
overnight.
And actually it's a little bit
more complicated because there
are two options.
You can actually,
in this fish,
be born as a female and then
turn into a male,
or you can be born as a male,
as a initial-phase male,
and then turn into an adult
dominant male.
And the initial-phase males are
female mimics.
They make their living by
sneaking fertilizations off of
dominant males.
The way that sex works in this
species is that that they live
on patch reefs,
or sometimes they live on a
larger reef;
and you'll see in a minute that
the size of the reef makes a big
difference to their lifestyle.
They normally swim up to spawn
near sunset on the down current
side of the reef.
When they spawn and their
fertilized eggs then are out
there,
in the ocean,
the current will--if they've
done it right--
the current will carry the eggs
away from the reef,
because if the eggs settle on
the reef,
the reef is a forest of open
mouths.
A coral head is basically a
whole bunch of little hydra,
just waiting to grab onto
anything that falls onto it.
And so the fish do their
reproduction at a time of day
when planktivores will not
easily see their eggs,
and in a water current that
carries the eggs away from the
reef.
And the way they do it is that
they come up off the reef and
they swim up in the water column
near the surface,
and one of these dominant males
will swim up with a whole school
of females with him,
and he will go through a dance
and spawn,
and he will release his sperm
and they will release their
eggs.
And if there is an opportunity,
one of these initial-phase
males will sneak in,
and because he looks like a
female,
he won't get beaten up,
by the big male,
and he will release his sperm
and grab some of the
fertilization opportunity.
So there's an interesting
question: how many should be
initial-phase males and how many
should be initial-phase females?
Well that's where the ecology
and behavior comes in.
These big, lunking,
dominant, terminal-phase males
can actually police a harem,
on a small reef,
and they can actually police an
area which is maybe the size of
this piece of furniture up here,
or down to about half that size.
If it gets much bigger than
that, then the females actually
are just wandering around
foraging,
looking for food,
and a female could wander down
to this end,
and if there was an
initial-phase male down at this
end,
he could grab copulations,
because there might be
disruptions,
as they go up at sunset,
and that the number of females
would have arisen to the point
where the dominant male couldn't
control all of the initial-phase
males.
So basically the idea is that
if the reef is small,
these guys do well.
The bigger the reef gets,
the better these do.
And you can interpret SF either
as success in sneaking
fertilizations,
or in some slightly less polite
terminology.
So this is some field data from
Panama, and it shows you what
proportion of the males are
actually initial-phase males.
Remember I said that you would
expect them to do better on the
large reefs, and you would
expect the dominant males to do
better on the big reefs.
And this axis down here is
1/square root of local
population size;
so actually populations are
getting bigger in that
direction, along this axis.
So in fact if you just--the
data's fairly noisy,
the transformation down here
does tend to squeeze the data
together a little bit,
but there is a significant
effect of reef size.
If you're on a small reef,
it's mostly terminal males.
The larger the reef gets,
the bigger the population gets,
the more initial-phase males
there are.
Now how do they know whether
they should be an initial-phase
male or an initial-phase female?
These guys, remember they go
out and they live in the
plankton, and then they come
back to a reef.
And there they are,
they're just a tiny little
fish,
and they're dropping down onto
a reef,
and from their
perspective--after all,
if you're just one centimeter
long,
you don't really know if you're
on a reef the size of this room
or on a reef the size of this
table.
So what cues could it use to
decide what kind of reef it's
on, and is it using a genetic
cue or is it a developmental
one?
Well, it's really not plausible
that this kind of switch would
be purely genetic,
because if it were purely
genetic, then you would be the
kind of fish that your parent
was,
but you might end up in an
environment where that way of
living was not appropriate,
because you're being spread out
over hundreds of kilometers out
there in the plankton and then
coming down on reefs of many
different sizes.
So there's some evidence that
the larvae are choosing their
sex based on density.
If you rear them in isolation,
the juveniles are almost always
differentiated as females.
So it's like the first one in
on the reef,
the default condition is to be
a female,
and that is regardless of
whether they came off a reef
with lots of primary males or
with a few primary males.
So it doesn't appear to be that
that's an inherited condition.
But if you have them reared in
groups of three,
one individual usually
differentiates as a primary
male.
So as the population size,
the cues of population size
start to accumulate,
some of them become primary
males rather than primary
females.
So this seems to be an
environmentally sensitive,
developmental strategy,
and it's probably evolved in
response to variation in
reproductive success of primary
males and populations of
different sizes.
That's a fairly stringent
logical condition;
and again the looking backwards
ploy is important.
This would never have evolved
if the genes had always been
experiencing reefs of the same
size, with similar social
conditions on each reef.
You only get a developmental
switch like this evolving if
there has been a regular
alternation of social conditions
for those young male wrasses to
encounter,
and if that has been the case
for long periods of time in the
past,
then the ones that have been
able to adjust appropriately
will have left more
grandchildren;
and that appears to be what's
going on here.
So if you would like,
if you're interested in this
kind of thing,
this is a good paper to get you
into that literature.
And remember,
if you're in ISI Web of
Science, you can both look
backwards and look forwards.
You can look at all papers
published in 2008 that cite this
paper that was published in
2006,
for example,
and you can do that with any
other question that you're
asking.
Now, what about a case of
protandry?
Well this is a case that shows
the default condition when there
really isn't very much
complicated social life.
This is a mollusk and it lives
on the Connecticut coastline.
And if you go out to
Hammonasset State Park,
which is up by Madison,
and you walk down the beach,
your shoes are crunching on the
shells of Crepidula fornicata;
that's basically what the beach
consists of is the shells of
Crepidula fornicata.
And these guys are born as
males and grow up and change
over to being females,
and they go through a stage
where they're both.
And, in fact,
they have a penis that extends
downward,
and so the males are actually
inseminating the hermaphrodites
that are in the middle,
and the hermaphrodites in the
middle are inseminating the
female that's on the bottom.
So Crepidula forms a daisy
chain as a standard part of its
life history.
This is how these things live,
and you can see the progression
just sitting there in one clump,
as they go through their life.
Okay, so the Shaw-Mohler
theorem actually tells us quite
a bit about the main questions
of sequential hermaphrodites.
Remember they are:
as what sex should I be born,
and at what age and size should
I change sex?
And by the way,
the existence of sequential
hermaphrodites leads us to
certain puzzles.
There are many,
as you'll see in a minute,
there are many mammals where it
would make a lot of sense to be
a sequential hermaphrodite,
but evidently we don't have a
reproductive system that's
flexible enough for that to have
evolved.
And I think you'll see--but
just stick that in your memory
for a few minutes,
because you're now going to see
a few mammals that would make
more sense to me as sequential
hermaphrodites.
We'll get into that with the
Trivers-Willard hypothesis.
So again this is Bob Trivers,
and with a guy named Willard he
came up with the idea that in a
polygynous species,
a low ranking female,
or a female in poor condition,
should have female biased
litters or clutches,
because their daughters can
always have offspring.
Females in these circumstances
are the limiting sex.
You do not have to be a highly
competitive female in a
polygynous species to get
inseminated.
There's going to be some male
that's going to get you
pregnant.
On the other hand,
high ranking females,
or females in good
physiological condition,
should have male-biased litters
or clutches.
The reason for that is that
their sons can only have
offspring if they can dominate.
So you're not going to invest
in a male offspring unless
you're pretty sure that it's
going to grow up and be able to
actually win competitions.
So the examples we'll look at
are red deer and chimpanzees,
and at the end I'll mention the
German farmers.
Okay?
So in red deer on the Island of
Rhum,
in Scotland,
where Tim Clutton-Brock and
Loeske Kruuk and Josephine
Pemberton and others--
Fiona Guinness--have studied
them now for thirty years,
they have followed many
individuals,
from birth to death,
and documented their social
rank and their reproductive
success and many aspects of
their behavioral ecology.
There is a great deal to be
learned from following
individual organisms from birth
to death,
because the variation you then
see in their lives tells you a
great deal about the selection
pressures that are operating on
them.
And what they observed was this.
Here over here,
on the y-axis,
you've got lifetime
reproductive success of male and
female offspring.
The closed circles are the
sons, and the open circles are
the daughters,
and this is the social rank of
the mother down here--
this is subordinate and
dominant--and this straight line
here is drawn just for the black
dots,
for the sons.
And what you can see is that
there is really not very much
influence of social rank on the
lifetime reproductive success of
daughters,
but there is an influence of
social rank on the lifetime
reproductive success of the
sons.
Now high ranking females in red
deer do give birth to more sons
than daughters.
They have a distorted sex ratio
at birth.
So the question is how do the
females do that?
Well they can be doing it with
sperm selection,
if they could detect whether
the sperm were X or Y bearing
sperm.
They could do it with selective
abortion, if somehow the
conflict between mother and
offspring has been resolved in
favor of the mother.
Just think about it.
There you are,
you're an embryonic red deer.
You happen to be the wrong sex
for this particular mother.
She has evolved to get rid of
you through abortion,
if you're the wrong type.
You will try to conceal your
sex.
You will not be expressing
whether you're a male or a
female in the surface proteins.
So there's a puzzle here.
How could selective abortion
evolve?
Because there is a conflict
between parent and offspring
about whether you should be able
to even detect what sex your
child is.
We don't know.
What we do know is this:
Nutrias do this--
nutrias are South-American
rodents--
and if you have a female nutria
who is subordinate or in low
physiological condition and she
should be making mostly female
offspring,
but she happens to have a
mostly male brood,
she just aborts the whole thing
and tries again.
So that's what she does.
The Seychelles warblers--so a
great place to go do fieldwork;
the Seychelles are just
lovely--there's a warbler that
lives in the Seychelles Islands
and they control the sex of
individual eggs,
and they do so--in order to
have the correct sex,
there is a helper at the nest
when they--
when the baby grows up they
actually have helpers at the
nest.
So whole families of warblers
help to feed the next
generation,
and what the mother is doing is
she's making the right kind of
egg for her ecological
condition.
Sometimes it's helpful to have
a lot of daughters and sometimes
it's not helpful to have a lot
of daughters,
and they can control the sex.
We don't know how they do it.
So there is definitely sex
allocation in red deer and in
nutrias and in Seychelles
warblers where the sex ratio at
birth is being changed in terms
of social or ecological
circumstances,
and it seems to be changed
appropriately.
Now with
chimpanzees--chimpanzees are
like us.
They have a 50:50 sex ratio at
birth,
and if you don't have selective
abortion,
you don't have effective sperm
selection,
it's hard to avoid a 50:50 sex
ratio at birth.
So sex chromosomes do that for
you.
However, you can still make
choices after the baby is born.
And this is the inter-birth
interval in months,
over here, and this line here
is for dominant mothers,
and this line here is for
sub-dominant mothers,
and this is about five years
and this is about seven years,
up here.
So it's about a two-year
difference.
And if a dominant mother gives
birth to a daughter,
she weans that daughter,
when that daughter's about five
years of age.
But if she gives birth to a
son, she keeps him for two more
years.
That is a high investment.
He's getting more and more
expensive to take care of and
she's losing time that she could
put into another child.
But because she's dominant and
she's got a son,
the argument is she'll get more
grandchildren if she invests in
him and really makes him into a
dominant male.
On the other hand--and by the
way, this is a highly
significant result here;
this one is marginally
insignificant down here--
a sub-dominant mother has a bit
more of a tendency to rear her
daughters longer and her sons
shorter and discard the sons
earlier.
Look at what happens to them.
This is the survivorship.
This is the age of the baby
here.
This is the son of a dominant
mother;
so these guys over here.
They aren't weaned until
they're seven-years-old.
As soon as they're weaned,
30% of them die,
but the rest of them have
extremely good survival,
and they in fact do better than
anybody else.
By age 13 they're just the best
survivor class that there is up
in this diagram.
Look at the sons of a
sub-dominant mother.
They're these guys here.
They are--this square--they are
neglected even before they're
weaned.
They aren't weaned until five
years.
So before they're weaned,
they're already doing worse,
and then once they're weaned
they only have a 20% probability
of becoming 13-years-old;
whereas those of a dominant
mother have nearly a 70%
probability of becoming
13-years-old.
You can see that there are
similar effects going on with
the daughters.
That's a very dramatic pattern.
Now, rearing a son at all,
if you're a sub-dominant
mother,
and you're going to kind of
neglect him and get rid of him
early,
is a very expensive thing.
So why is it that they haven't
evolved screening mechanisms,
at the sperm or the zygote
stage, that respond to social
rank?
We don't know.
It would be very adaptive for
them to do that.
And I'll now tell you about the
German farmers.
Klaus Voland,
in Germany, has analyzed the
demographic data sets of a set
of Northwestern German farming
communities from the seventeenth
and eighteenth century,
through the nineteenth century.
And during this time there were
economic cycles.
When times were good,
it was possible for a son to
inherit a farm.
When times were bad,
the sons couldn't inherit
anything, or only one son could
inherit the farm,
but in bad times daughters
could still marry up.
And what Voland showed is that
the probability that a son or a
daughter would survive to
maturity was dependent upon the
economic cycle,
pretty much in the same way
that we just saw for the
chimpanzees.
In other words,
German farmers invested more in
sons when sons could inherit,
and they invested more in
daughters when daughters could
marry up,
and the degree of investment
was actually reflected in the
mortality rates of the children.
So it had to do with parental
neglect.
So that is one case where it
does look like the
Trivers-Willard hypothesis
actually works in humans.
To be fair to the data,
I want to mention some of the
other cases.
There have been large-scale
studies in the United States
that show that this effect is
fairly weak,
and there have been some other
studies in the United States
that show that this effect is
fairly strong.
So the evidence is mixed on
this one.
And I would like to emphasize
that in humans it could very
well be cultural rather than
genetic.
After all, people generally do
talk about issues like this,
and they are understood within
families.
So it's possible that patterns
of parenting could be culturally
as well as genetically
influenced.
However, what one can say is
that that's perfectly consistent
with the Trivers-Willard
hypothesis.
It's just that it might have a
cultural rather than an
evolutionary explanation.
So I think that the Shaw-Mohler
theorem is a case in which very
disparate kinds of information
are being brought together and
explained in the same
theoretical framework.
Remember, we've looked today at
sex ratios in mites where you
have incest and cannibalism
going on.
We have looked at sex change in
hermaphroditic fish,
sequentially hermaphroditic
fish, and we have looked at the
investment in offspring of the
two different sexes in red deer
and in chimpanzees;
and that's really quite a range
of biological information.
If you get into the sex
allocation literature,
you will find hundreds of more
cases where the Shaw-Mohler
theorem works.
So it indicates that it has
captured something that's very
important about evolutionary
biology.
And to remind you of that,
it's the fact that in a
sexually reproducing population
every diploid adult is getting
half of its genome from its
father and half of its genome
from its mother,
and the consequence of that is
that the male and the female
paths to fitness are equivalent.
So this is a very fundamental
structuring fact about much of
the sexual biology of organisms.
In sex allocation we've seen
that there are really quite
strong connections between
mating systems,
social structure,
sexual selection,
population structure,
life history evolution and
genetic systems.
Let me test your understanding
of what I've said today about
male and female function being
equivalent paths to fitness,
and about the Shaw-Mohler
theorem.
There is a shrimp--and you have
all probably eaten it in your
dinning halls--which is born
male and changes to female.
And let us suppose that this
shrimp, before there was ever a
fishery for it,
made the sex change when it was
three-years-old.
So when it was small it was a
male, it changed to a female at
three years, and then it lived
the rest of its life as a
female.
Male and female function are
equivalent paths to fitness.
Now, we create a fishery,
and the fishery goes in and it
starts catching all those nice
big fat females,
because they're the biggest
ones, and the fishery operates
long enough for there to be an
evolutionary response.
What happens to the age at sex
change?
Student:  It's longer.
Prof: What?
Student: It's longer.
Prof: No,
they do not spend longer as
males.
So now you know the answer.
But I want to know why.
What happens is that they
change sex at two-years,
rather than at three-years.
What's happened is that the
fishery has been taking away
their female function,
and evolution wants them to get
half of their fitness through
male function and half of it
through female function.
In order to maintain that
equivalency, it has to create
more space in the life through
the females.
The fishery is taking away
space in the life to be female,
and so the sex ratio,
the sex change shifts to an
earlier point.
This is exactly what's
happened, and if you buy fish at
A1 Fish Market,
or you have them in the dining
hall,
you will get shrimp in those
fish markets that do this,
and they have responded to the
human selection pressure created
by the fishery,
and it's changed the age and
size at which they change sex.
This is actually one of the
reasons why this course is
called Principles of Evolution,
Ecology and Behavior.
It's because there are examples
like this where it doesn't make
any sense to separate these
fields.
All of this stuff is going on,
in these examples.
You have dominant behavior,
you have ecology,
population density and
evolution all interacting with
each other.
Okay, so next time sexual
selection.